mais tout de suite dans les rues de la
capitale ont rejoint notre autre
reporter guillemin rosie qui suit lui la
manifestation des gilet jaune
bonjour argué main alors les opposants à
la politique sanitaire du gouvernement
sont nombreux à défiler à paris
aujourd'hui
et oui tout à fait amira en tout cas on
le retrouve dans don dans de nombreux
rassemblements ce samedi il y à vous
l'avez dit les patriotes emmené par
florian philippot et puis comme chaque
samedi bien entendu les manifestations
de jets jaune que l'on retrouve dans
plusieurs points de la capitale alors un
rassemblement devait se tenir ce matin
place de la république et puis les
cortèges sont partis d'un petit peu
partout depuis à la place d'italie
depuis à la place de la bourse et bien
sûr il ya le cortège dans lequel je me
trouve actuellement qui est partie de la
porte de clichy il ya un peu moins d'une
heure environ plusieurs centaines de
personnes qui se dirige actuellement
vers la place de la bastille alors côté
revendications retrouve un panel assez
large lutte contre les violences d'état
soutient aux tomtom ou je vous rappelle
un couvre-feu est toujours en vigueur en
martinique et puis et demande de
davantage de justice sociale de
démocratie participative ce sont là
d'ailleurs les revendications que l'on
retrouvait déjà au tout début de ce
mouvement d gilet jaune il ya plus de
trois ans et je vous propose d'écouter
un jérôme rodriguez figure bien connue
maintenant des gilet jaune écouter
bakou d'être sur la continuité à défaut
de rester chez soi être que les contres
son nouveau-né contre sa machine à café
je pense qu'elle est toujours important
de pouvoir manifester essayer de se
faire entendre sur l'ensemble des
revendications qu'on essaye d'apporter
pour améliorer aujourd'hui le quotidien
des français ce fameux mieux vivre que
l'on réclame depuis trois ans et puis
malheureusement aujourd'hui un toutes
ces mesures liberticides parce que le
pass vaccinale c'est pas la seule y en a
eu beaucoup on a eu beaucoup d'autres
avant celle ci est bien de pouvoir
récupérer la liberté des français et de
pouvoir retrouver un semblant de vie et
surtout pour nos gamins aussi
alors vous l'avez entendu la lutte
contre le pass vaccinale et contre
l'obligation contre la vaccination
obligatoire de certaines professions
figurent également parmi les
revendications des gilet jaune
aujourd'hui et ce alors que la pandémie
que l'épidémie recule dans l'hexagone et
qu'on s'attend à un allègement de
certaines mesures et de certaines
contraintes sanitaires d'ici les
semaines et les mois à venir en tout cas
c'est ce qu'on espère parmi les
manifestants dans ce cortège aujourd'hui
merci à guillaume 1 pour toutes ces
précisions